Radha: Often people will write me an email,
like a young person will write me an email
like, “Hey, can we get together for coffee?”
And then I won’t respond just to see if
they’ll write me again.
Because there’s something in that!
Like I would write my mentors probably 20
times until I got a response.
Miki Agrawal: I showed up, like a stalker.
Radha Agrawal: Yeah.
We find out like— this one guy I wanted
to get in touch with, I called his landline
like 20 times, he wouldn’t pick up, and
then I found out where he was speaking in
New York City and then I went there, and I
was just, like afterwards I was like, “Hey
what’s up?”
And he became the head researcher of one of
my big projects!
And so I think the resilience and never giving
up, persistence is something that sports has
taught us, and I think that we can all be
so sort of timid at times to continue reaching
out again.
Like my best friend Max, when I first started
hanging out with him he was 22 at the time
and I was 32 – he’s our best friend.
Okay.
Sorry.
Our best friend Max, he was 22 and we were
32, and we met him on a vacation and when
he came back to New York he would just text
me all the time he would say “Hey want to
hang out?”
And I was like, “No I don’t want to hang
out with a 22 year old kid, no thanks.”
But then he just kept texting me over and
over again and be like, “Hey I’m in the
neighborhood!”
Miki Agrawal: And just kept showing up—
first person at the party, last person to
leave.
Radha Agrawal: Yeah.
And he would show up all the time.
And then finally he came to one of our parties
and we realized how smart and thoughtful and
interesting he was, and he’s now our best
friend.
So I think that perseverance is something
that we aren’t often taught and it just—keep
going up.
And especially as women we’re so empathetic
that in some ways our empathy becomes our
fuel for fear.
Empathy becomes fuel for fear because when
we care so much about what someone else thinks
it stops us from actually wanting to step
on anyone’s toes.
“I don’t want to bother them again.”
And if you just take on that attitude you’re
never going to get to where you want to go.
Miki Agrawal: And the worst that happens is
rejection.
Radha Agrawal: Yeah.
Exactly.
And so I think because, again, we had each
other, this is why I wrote a book called Belong.
It’s all about finding your tribe and create
community.
When you have a tribe that supports you and
that really makes you feel safe and gives
you wings, you don’t feel weird reaching
out to people because you already have friends!
You’re like, “Yeah I called this guy and
he didn’t respond, what are you going to
do?”
And then Miki would be like “Call him again!”
or “Call her again!”
And so you have friends and community members
who are there to build you up when you’re
sort of down.
So I think step one in anything that you do
in life, like no matter what it is whether
it’s a business, whether it’s just anything
sort of related to something that’s difficult,
is to start first with finding your tribe,
finding your community, building your people.
Because when you feel a sense of belonging,
when you feel that sense of “oh my God I’m
safe I’m here,” that’s how Daybreaker
became a thing, that’s how it grew into
a half-a-million-person movement around the
world that it is today in 23 cities.
Because first I spent five years building
my tribe really developing and deepening my
tribe, my community, who then when I launched
our very first Daybreaker that December 10th
first snowfall in New York City in 2013, everybody
could have slept in, they could’ve been
like “No I’m not going to that thing,”
but everyone showed up.
We had 200 people who showed up to our very
first event because they were my friends and
they cared about me, and I had nurtured those
relationships.
And so that’s the first baseline layer to
anything that we do in life, is first put
down your computer and go meet your friend
for that drink, go meet your friend for that
dinner, because you just can’t even imagine
how in the moments that you meet them how
much they’ll be there for you.
And particularly, representing a business,
it is so deeply critical too to the have those
friends they can be like “Oh I went to this
investor and they said no to me.”
Instead of taking you into a downward spiral
your friends lift you back up again, so I
can’t even say that enough, it’s the most
important thing that we can do, is to find
your tribe and feel a sense of belonging.
Miki Agrawal: At the time and nobody wanted
to talk about periods, not a single press
wanted to talk about it.
“America is not ready to talk about this
Miki,” that was what I got every single
day in 2013/’14, et cetera, and it was really,
really, really hard.
And so in 2015 we scaled the business enough
digitally that we wanted to launch our first
out of home campaign, our first subway advertisements.
And we were so excited: my team spent two
weeks sleeping under their desks designing
these incredible campaigns, and we ran up
against an issue, which was the New York City
public transit system officials basically
said that they could not publish our ads in
the subway because of the word “period.”
And they said people in the subway will be
offended by it, “it’s offensive to riders.”
And we were like, “Interesting… you said
that.
And Oh No You Didn’t!”
And it was a powerful moment, that in the
rest of the world periods are so taboo, in
Nepal women are still sleeping outside because
if they sleep inside their homes on their
periods then “snakes will come eat their
dads,” literally, or the husbands.
That’s literally still happening.
And so the fact that in the most progressive
city in the world, New York City, we could
not put the word “period” in the subways,
was really like “wow,” it really brought
this sort of…
Radha Agrawal: Why like grapefruits could
be put on your breasts, like there’s so
many other sort of breast augmentation ads,
so many other sort of very sexual ads that
could be on subways, but not periods.
Miki Agrawal: Yeah.
It was really crazy.
So there was such a double standard even used
grapefruits to represent augmented breasts
but you couldn’t use it to represent a woman’s
“part” that every single human is here
because of, that important time of the month—not
man, not one man, not one woman could be here
without that important nutrients to feed the
baby as we’re in utero.
So the fact that it’s considered taboo is
crazy, and so we decided instead of just slinking
away and put away this idea of doing New York
City subway campaign, we were like “Fuck
it we’re going to go fight it.”
And we put out - we basically sent an email
out to all press, which when we threatened
the New York City public transit system we
were like “we’re going to go to press,”
and they were like, “Go ahead.”
And we were like “You called my bluff; I
don’t know any press.
Shit.”
And so I like found two contacts in press
that knew…
Radha Agrawal: I’ll never forget this, Miki
and I were DJing that night, do you remember
that?
We were DJing a party that night some non-profit
party, whatever, and Miki was like, “Oh
my god they wrote me back!”
I’m like, “What do you mean?”
She’s was like, “I put subject line: SCANDAL.
NEW YORK CITY SCANDAL! and sent it to all
this press and media,” and one of them wrote
her back.
And I remember she was like on her phone we’re
like in the middle of a DJ set and she’s
like, “Oh holy shit someone wrote us back.”
Miki Agrawal: And it was so funny because
Forbes and Mic.com both wanted the exclusive.
At the time I was like, “You both can have
the exclusive!”
And they were like, “That’s not how it
works.”
And I was like, what do you mean?!
Like, no one is paying me money, so what are
you talking, “exclusive”?
I didn’t even know, like I thought exclusive
meant they were paying money.
So I got actually in trouble because I gave
them both the exclusive and eventually Forbes
backed down and Mic.com took the story, and
it went viral—internationally.
And I will never ever forget the moment where
it, like the way I think about it is when
you’re in the subways like you see those
people like singing music and playing the
guitar and like people are throwing like change
at them, I felt like we were singing our hearts
out trying to build, you know, create this
product and I’ll never forget when I was
like walking down Bedford Avenue in Williamsburg
after this story went viral, and I was walking
down the street and I ran into this Indian
guy named Sham and his two like super trendy,
cool, like, Indian nieces from India like
they’re both like—just fabulous.
And Sham was like, “Oh Miki, tell my nieces
what you’re working on.”
And I was like, “It’s this period proof
underwear company called Thinx.”
And both of these women were like, “Wait
a minute.
Wait a minute.
Wait a minute.”
And I was like, “What?
What?”
They both pulled out of their phones and literally
they were both on separate WhatsApp text threads
with all of their girlfriends and they were
all talking about Thinx.
And I remember that moment I was just like
I just remember like imprinting that moment,
and just like—I like teared up and they’re
like “What’s going—?” and I was just
like “Wow that’s great.
Of course you know
Thinx."
No I didn’t say that I would just, like,
“Wow you know it?”
Like in my head I was trying to be cool but
actually what came out was not.
Anyway, I was just so incredulous, and I like
will never forget that moment.
It was like I felt like someone heard my song
and they were singing it and like they were
singing along, and you’re just like – And
then from that moment we just took off.